The time is coming when the human race
will get to the moon,
with rockets!
Private companies won't want to do this,
how are they gonna make money?
By charging for the ride.
Those crazy billionaires competing with each other.
Modern day rocket man wants to send you to Mars.
Difficult.
Dangerous.
Good chance you will die.
The private industry's space race
it's on.
We tend to think that space exploration and
human space flight is all about
governmental agencies like NASA.
But it wasn't really always like that.
Some of the very first steps by
the early rocketry pioneers
were funded by the private sector.
In the U.S. it begins with
the University of Clark professor
Robert Goddard.
It’s 1920 and he publishes
"A Method of Reaching Extreme Altitudes”
mentioning that rockets could be used
to carry payloads to the moon.
They called him the "Moon Man" and laughed.
The Times editorial writer
implied that your husband didn’t even know
high school physics.
He did not let such things deter him from
his experiments.
In 1926 Goddard successfully launches the
first liquid-fueled rocket.
Money from the family of the mining magnate
Daniel Guggenheim soon follows.
They provided him funding in today's dollars
at the scale of tens of millions of dollars.
What's interesting is that at the very start
of this period of the 1920s
there was actually a great amount of enthusiasm
and a great amount of belief
in the potential for these private rockets to go to space.
The German war machine gets under way.
The Second World War gives rockets a whole
new meaning.
And then the knowledge of rocketry
became critical to the Cold War.
And in the ‘50s and ‘60s rocketry was almost
exclusively a governmental affair.
The private sector, in terms of companies,
was essentially working as contractors to
the U.S. government.
It’s not until 1982, that a serious effort
is made to build a privately funded rocket.
The idea comes from a Texas businessman,
David Hannah Jr.
Conestoga 1 is pieced together from a
repurposed ballistic missile.
It may not have had the majesty of an Apollo,
or the thunder of a Shuttle
but it flew and that’s what counts.
Everything speeds up at the turn of the millennium
when freshly minted millionaires take interest.
One of them is Jeff Bezos.
I don’t actually hold out great hopes.
But If I could do anything,
I would like to go help explore space.
A few months later he sets up Blue Origin.
Then Elon Musk starts SpaceX.
And yet another tech millionaire
Anousheh Ansari and her family
promise to foot the bill for XPrize.
This is a $10 million award for reaching the
industry’s holy grail -
a reusable manned space vehicle.
In 2004 SpaceShipOne wins the prize.
There it is, a craft that has been to space
and back, today right in front of you.
Richard Branson buys the rights,
turns it into Virgin Galactic
and in the same year starts accepting commercial
reservations for future suborbital flights.
Although we are seeing a lot of billionaires
have interest in space flight,
their investments still pale in comparison to governmental investments.
And they have now managed to partner in many
cases with U.S. government agencies.
NASA for example is in most years
SpaceX's primary customer.
But there are setbacks.
Local company's mission for NASA
explodes into a ball of fire and debris.
Deadly crash involving Virgin Galactic’s
SpaceShipTwo.
A SpaceX rocket bringing supplies for
the International Space Station
as you can see there, it exploded!
Eventually, in 2015 Blue Origin’s New Shepard rocket
becomes the first to take off and land vertically
after reaching space.
Shortly after SpaceX goes even further, sending
its Falcon 9 to orbit altitude.
The other major milestone will be the first
tourists on commercial suborbital vehicles.
And I'm not gonna predict who's gonna be there first but
the hope is that by having
more competition amongst commercial companies
and by leveraging advanced technologies that
we're gonna be able to
reduce the cost of going into space.
2019 is the year that SpaceX and Boeing are
gearing up to finally take astronauts
up to the International Space Station.
The first private lunar lander is on its way
to the Moon
and Chinese companies are joining the space
race as well.
For well over a hundred years, people have been
dreaming and thinking and planning
for a future for humanity beyond this planet.
And that includes a future for humanity on
the surface of the moon,
a future for humanity on Mars
and even farther still.
And as long as we have a social goal of continuing
to expand our knowledge of the cosmos,
then the ambitions and dreams of individuals
are gonna be an important part of realizing those goals.